you mentioned the infinity problem and
the Hawking problem uh witch Hocking
problem the the that the black hole
destroys information or that the what
what which Hawking problem are we
talking about well there's really two
Hawking problems they're very closely
related
um one is how does the black hole store
the information
and
um
that is the one that we solved in some
cases so it's sort of like uh you know
your your smartphone
how does it store its 64 gigabytes well
you rip the cover off and you count the
chips and there's 64 of them each with a
gigabyte and you know they're 64
gigabytes
but that does not solve the problem of
how you get information in and out of
your smartphone
you have to understand a lot more about
the Wi-Fi and the internet and the
cellular and and that's where Hawking
radiation this prediction it starts
that's where Hawking radiation comes in
and that problem of how the information
gets in and out you can't you couldn't
have explained how information gets in
and out of an iPhone without first
explaining
how it's stored in the first place
so just to clarify the storage is on the
plate on the flight on the holographic
plate and then it projects somehow
inside the the bulk the the space time
is the Hologram the Hologram but man I
mean did you have an intuitive when you
sit late at night and you stare at the
stars do you have any intuitive
understanding what a holographic plate
is
um like that there's two Dimension you
know projections that store information
how a black hole
could store information on a holographic
plate
I think we do understand in in great
mathematical detailing also intuitively
and it's very much like an ordinary
hologram or a whole of a holographic
plate and you it contains all the
information you shine a light through it
and you get an image which looks
three-dimensional yeah but why should
there be a holographic plate
like what
why should there be yeah why
that is the Great thing about being a
theoretical physicist is
anybody can very quickly stump you if
they going to the next level of wise
yeah so I can just keep asking yeah you
could just keep asking and it won't take
you very long to
so the trick in being a theory a
theoretical physics is finding the
questions that
you can answer sure so so the questions
that we think we might be able to answer
now and we've partially answered
is that
um there is a holographic
explanation for certain
kinds of things and string theory Sure
we've answered that now we'd like to
take what we've learned and that's what
I've mostly been doing for the last 15
20 years I haven't really been working
so much on string theory proper I've
been sort of taking the lessons that you
we learned in string theory and trying
to apply them to the real world
using only
assuming only what we know for sure
about the real world so on this uh topic
you you co-wrote co-authored the paper
with Stephen Hawking called soft hair on
black holes yes that makes the argument
against Hawking's original prediction
that black holes destroy information can
you explain this paper
yeah and the title yeah okay so um first
of all
um
the hair on black holes
is a word that was coined by the
greatest phrase master in the history of
physics John Wheeler invented the word
black hole
and he also said that he made the
statement that black holes have no hair
that is every black hole in the universe
is described just by its mass and spin
they wrote they can also rotate as was
later shown by Kerr
and
um
and this is very much unlike a star
right every Star of the same
mass is different
in a multitude of different ways
different chemical compositions
different motions
of the individual molecules every star
in the universe
even of the same mass is different in
many many different ways
black holes are all the same
and that means when you throw some in
Einstein's description of them which we
think must be corrected
and um
if you throw something into a black hole
it gets sucked in
and if you uh throw in a red book or a
Blue Book
the black hole gets a little bigger but
there's no way within Einstein's theory
of telling how they're different
and that was one of the assumptions
that Hawking made in his
1974-75 papers in which he concluded
that black holes destroy information you
can throw encyclopedias thesis defenses
the Library of Congress it doesn't
matter it's going to behave exactly the
same uniform way yeah so what what
Hawking and I showed and also Malcolm
Perry
um
is that one has to be very careful about
what happens
at the boundary of the black hole
and this gets back to something I
mentioned earlier about when two things
which are related by a coordinate
transformation are and are not
equivalent
and
um
and what we showed is that they're very
subtle imprints when you throw something
into a black hole
they're very subtle imprints left on the
horizon of the black hole which you can
read off at least partially what went in
and
um so this
invalidates uh Steven's original
uh argument that the information is
destroyed and that's the soft hair
that's the soft hair right so and soft
is the word that is used in physics for
things which have very low energy and
these things actually carry no energy
there are things in the universe which
carry no energy